thank you well first of all I can't beat
wills bowtie and frankly no no nor can I
beat his very charming southern accent
coming from London these days I don't
hear that very often at all delighted to
be here
thanks for the very kind introduction
frankly the best part of the
introduction is if you all step outside
there's this little board that says you
know speaker series around surin CEO of
Vodafone
and Verizon I wish that were the case
just to be technically correct about
this I'm only the CEO of Vodafone if
Ivan Seidenberg listens into this
situation he would be particularly
interested in knowing that I have made
this distinction very clearly now I'm
delighted to be here first of all I'm
delighted because I see so many young
faces faces that I think will be the
future leaders of great companies and
great institutions in the future but I'm
also very happy to be here because I've
brought some sunshine for you it's not
very often that you come from London and
people are thanking you for the sunshine
that you reign and equally I can't see
my daughter here in the audience but my
daughter is here and this is she's a
graduating senior so I look forward to
Nina graduating and we'll be back in
June as parents but anyway very nice to
be here now I'd like to do four things
real quickly off the 60 or so minutes 20
minutes or so I'd like to talk to you
and 40 minutes or so let's engage in Q&A
but I want to paint a picture for you
and the first picture is about what is
the state of business in the world and
when I think about you
myself what is it that you all will need
to know and confront in the next 10 20
years of your working life what is it
that you need to know and I'm going to
try and point that out as clearly as I
can so I want to talk about China and I
want to talk about the European Union
those would be the two areas I want to
talk about we can talk about any country
we want to talk about but those would be
the two I want to highlight the second
is kind of the state of the
communications industry there's a lot
going on in the comms industry you're
sitting here in the middle of Silicon
Valley there are 50 great ideas going on
now and I want to give you a perspective
as to please from where we sit from
where I sit how is the cookie going to
crumble what's going to happen how are
new things gonna happen I want to paint
that picture for you the third picture I
want to paint for you is kind of what is
the state of Vodafone where's Vodafone
today and where's Vodafone going in the
future as an example of one major player
in the communications industry and the
last thing is around leadership you know
having been in business now for 25 years
I've watched many many great leaders the
question is are there any common themes
for great leaders big companies small
companies startup company whatever it is
sports teams leading nations
institutions whatever it is are there
common elements to leadership and then
after that I'll open it up for Q&A so
that's what I intend to do for the next
20 minutes hopefully I have your
approval okay so let's start with kind
of the state of business in the world
and let me first start with a high
growth economy a high growth economy
like China and I'm going to spend a lot
of time telling you what you either know
or there are many other people who are
better qualified to tell you about China
and the fantastic growth and the change
from an agrarian economy to an
industrialized economy that's not my
point of talking about China to you
today my point about talking about China
to you is you are going to have to be
very comfortable doing business in China
so for those of you who don't have
passports so for those of you who
haven't traveled get your passport
travel the China
go out there see you know within a
matter of months and years how much
China is changing I personally find it
fascinating when I go to Beijing or
Shanghai you know I was there a year ago
two years ago three years ago the amount
of change that's occurred three years
ago lots of bicycles today hardly any
bicycles all cars three years ago
lots of organized bicycles going down a
road today cars going everywhere not as
bad as in India but pretty close all
right the point is you as future leaders
are going to have to be comfortable
doing business in China so get used to
that idea question but the question
becomes you know from a business point
of view what is important to remember
about China from a business point of
view what's important to remember about
China is that it is a very large market
we have a company there called China
mobile we have 300 million users in
China 300 million all told there are 400
million mobile phone users in China
it'll soon be six seven eight hundred
million again the importance here is
that China is such a large market that
they will develop their own standards so
what I would standard they go on to and
lock on to the rest of the world is
going to have to get used to dealing
with those standards
now is there a little conflict here that
any of you are feeling or whatever
because frankly for the last 50 years
the United States has been in that
position the United States has been in
the position whether it's
telecommunication standards computing
standards automobile standards we've set
the die as it were and the point here is
because of the size of their market they
are going to now start setting the diet
we're seeing it already in the
telecommunications business you know
we've got a standard it's called WCDMA
that we're trying to you know have
everybody around the world use so that
you can take your mobile phone anywhere
in the world and it works and all of
that well the Chinese government is
promoting in an alternate
now the system is not as good as WCDMA
but who cares it's like we're gonna do
this and we're gonna press it in to
China
it'll get big we'll have economy as a
scale we'll have a bunch of
manufacturers Huawei and ZTE and others
kind of manufacture this stuff and we'll
take it around the world now this is not
the next two years plan this is the next
10 years plan this is the next 20 years
plan so whatever industry you're in
it doesn't matter watch because China is
going to be a big player in the
marketplace you can come back and do Q&A
on this if you'd like the other place I
want to go to is the European Union now
the European Union is classically low
growth while China is high growth EU is
low growth there's a lot of talk about
EU does not talk about European Union
and how this is going to be another 400
million person economy competing with
the United States possibly I I think
the EU has a lot of work to do before it
becomes a truly European Union I find if
we've got very large businesses in
Germany Italy Spain the UK France
everywhere I still find the notion of
economic Union and European Union pretty
far away from reality you can talk all
you want about it you can think about
the institutions that exist and the
speed at which they're morphing I think
there's a long ways to go here frankly
now the things that you need to watch
there is first of all please be
comfortable doing business in Europe as
well so this is not just about China but
it's also about Europe but you have a
little more time and what I'd say about
the European Union is that there are two
key things one is that the new countries
the new countries that have acceded to
the EU recently are much more dynamic
much more ready to kind of do things
much more energetic than frankly the old
EU countries and in the old yo countries
you have to
have catcher like changes big reforms to
hiring firing capital formation all of
those things for those countries to kind
of make the difference that they'll have
to make in the future yeah so that's
kind of state of state of the business
in the world let me move on to the
communications industry in the
communications industry all the things
that you can think of classically in
terms of what do consumers want is
technology changing our new competitors
coming in is regulation changing just
about anything that you can think of
it's going on in our industry it's
almost like a perfect storm in some ways
there is massive upheaval there's
massive change and the kinds of
companies whether it's vertical on a
Verizon or Comcast or any one of these
companies that you might be familiar
with all these companies are going to
change five 10 years from now these
companies are not going to look anything
like the company that you see before you
today now within this space I want to
kind of talk about two things one is
convergence convergence is basically
another way of thinking about
convergence is three screens you've got
a you've got a television screen you've
got a computer screen and you've got a
mobile phone screen how do these three
screens interact with each other who
provides content to these three screens
and who does all the kind of magic in
the back as it were whether it's
middleware or access or whatever to kind
of make these three screens work
together now most of you are too young
to remember this whole convergence idea
first came to the fore in the early to
mid 1990s and everybody talked about it
and nothing happened then again when web
1.0 malong in the late 1990s there was
another round of big convergence talk
and all of these things are going to
come together and the way most people
talked about it was that Vodafone will
get married to Verizon will get married
to Comcast and so you've got all of
these different screens kind of coming
together in terms of merges well much of
that hasn't happen
some of it is unlikely to happen and
it's unlikely to happen because of
destructive technology there is a lot of
destructive technology much of it within
50 miles radius of here that is being
generated that's going to change how
these three screens work together so the
thing to remember about the
communications industry is first of all
customers and I don't think this is
limited to the communications industry
is that customers have a big say in the
pace at which our industry will change
and while customers didn't want what
people were serving them in 1995 or in
2000 in the next five years
customers will change their minds
because more and more of us are now
getting tired of the fact that our
phones don't sync with our computers
don't sync with our television and all
of that and people are saying how come
and the consumer attitude is very much
of you know faster cheaper better so
that's kind of what's going on in the
communication space now let's talk a
little bit about Vodafone Vodafone is a
large company our market cap is a
hundred and fifty billion dollars we
have 60,000 employees
we're in 30 countries we have a hundred
and eighty million customers each of
these customers gives us roughly $40 a
month and our free cash flow that we
produce is about 12 billion dollars a
year this is free cash flow after
everything right so it's a big company
and but here's a company that if you now
circa ruin everything you've been
talking about in the last five minutes
in terms of the communications
infrastructure how does this company
kind of fit into that larger picture and
what's going to happen to you guys as
time goes forward so we've recently
reorganized our business into three
businesses and I'm these are not the
terms that we use internally but I'll
make it simple for you to kind of think
about them one is kind of mature
businesses so all our businesses in
Germany Italy UK etc in the Muar
category and what we're doing there is
we've introduced a new generation of
technology where you can get a mobile TV
on your phone you can download music on
your phone you can sync with your phone
you can do all of the you know classic
things outside of mobile telephony and
texting obviously any time you say
mature you have to say and therefore you
have to be concerned about costs so
we're reducing costs very aggressively
in that part of our business the second
part of our business is emerging markets
so we've got very interesting companies
in South Africa in India in Romania in
the Czech Republic and Hungary a bunch
of other places fast growth our strategy
there is very different our strategy
there is market share go grab market
share and new product introductions one
of the things that I personally find
fascinating is if you go to a country
like South Africa or India the way
people use their mobile phones I'm sorry
if I'm confusing with mobile phones cell
phones they are interchangeable when I'm
here I'm meant to say cell phones when
you're in Europe you're meant to say
mobile phones if you say mobile phones
in Europe people know immediately that
you've come from America where any rate
so how people use their mobile phones is
very different so people are doing
payments basically it's almost like a
currency in South Africa I go buy a bag
of potatoes and I can either pay for my
bag of potatoes using my cell phone or
more importantly I can exchange minutes
essentially it's a barter system so
those of you who are interested in kind
of economics and and kind of Federal
Reserve stuff and currency stuff you
know 10 15 years from now we may have to
rethink in some ways what is currency
what is M 1 what is M 2 and all that
good stuff but the point for now is
simply where there isn't a deep existing
infrastructure for an institution such
as financial services mobile phones are
doing financial services
equally there are other great ideas that
people are using mobile phones that and
frankly one of the reasons for us to be
in an emerging market is because there
are some of the best ideas that we're
getting are actually from some of the
emerging markets because people are much
freer to think about what it is they
want to do with their mobile phones the
third business that we've got is is an
area that we are calling new businesses
and here what we're trying to do is all
the classic barriers that customers see
for example I can imagine many of you
sitting on your personal computers you
know being doing I am and having your
mobile phone and being frustrated by the
fact that a friend of yours who you'd
like to kind of engage in an IM chat
with is not on their PC well very soon
we're going to be introducing products
where it doesn't matter whether you're
on your mobile phone or you're on your
PC you'll be able to get an iamb
community around you
that includes mobile phones so as long
as your friends mobile phone is turned
on essentially they'll show up on your
buddy list and you can have a
conversation with them right the other
frustration that a lot of customers have
is around you know your going to your
home how many vendors do I need to deal
with here somebody gives me broadband
somebody gives me long-distance somebody
gives me cable so we're going to be in a
business where you buy all your products
from us and our view is you're you only
really need two products you need a big
broadband pipe to your home or office or
whatever and you need a mobile phone
with fabulously big minute bundles
essentially between those two things
essentially you're taking care of and so
what you'll see us do is get into these
spaces and build the revenue base of our
business the number one challenge that
we have at Vodafone is how do you keep a
hundred and fifty billion dollar company
growing in a profitable way because you
think about large companies you think
about Microsoft you think about Intel
think about Walmart all of these
companies the biggest thing about GE
have a big problem developing profitable
growth
because we are so large and to find
large quantities of profitable growth is
the biggest challenge that our firm like
us face I move on to the last item I
want to chat with you about which is
around leadership in my view there are
at least three things that I find common
among leaders one is leaders have a very
good ability to have a good strategic
view of the world you have to know kind
of in whatever industry you know how the
cookie is going to crumble in the future
because if you don't have a view
sometimes wrongly but you have to have a
view you have to have a view of how the
cookie is gonna crumble where are you
taking this institution in the future
very clear if you're not clear people
are confused so typically leaders will
have a point of view about the future
and where they are trying to take their
institutions or their countries or
whatever they happen to be leading and
having a strategic view is very
important the second is that there is an
element of what I'll call operational
leadership which is just having a good
strategic view is not good enough you
actually have to have goals that you're
achieving and milestones that you're
passing as you go along here so being
good from a thinking perspective not
good enough you actually have to be able
to execute and execute flawlessly with
your team and the third is people
leadership you have to be good with
people if you're not good with people
chances are that you will not end up
being a leader at least of a large
institution simply because people want
to be led by people that they feel
comfortable with that they feel like
that they want to follow a particular
leader so the notion of human leadership
in people leadership is tremendously
important so you could be the smartest
person but if you don't have good people
leadership skills that's going to stunt
your growth
the third thing I'd say about this is
that it's an end situation meaning it is
strategy plus operations plus people
leadership it's not or the minute you
put an oar in there unlikely that you're
going to kind of make it to the very top
so it's an end thing so the the reason
I'm pointing this out to you today is
because often times people aren't as
clear about this early in their in their
lives and the point here is you know one
might do a put self-assessment and say
you know am I have good people leader
and at your age you know you don't
really know some of you probably do but
some of you don't the point is if you
work on it I can assure you you can be a
good people leader so it's not one of
these things which is gosh you know I'll
never ever be a good people leader if
you're not sure about your execution
skills and your operational skills well
go to work on it if you're not sure
about your strategic skills well go to
work on it because you have a career in
front of you but as long as it's
consciously in your in your head that
you have to do these things well
simultaneously to go to where you want
to go then you can you can learn along
the way I'm not in the camp that says
that people are born leaders and you
know if you aren't born a leader no way
that you can become a leader I disagree
with that I think leadership is a
completely practiced art and if you
think it's easy to kind of stand up here
and answer questions and give speeches
and lead a company and all that all
comes naturally no it doesn't it's all
practice it's all practice you work on
it every day and you get better as time
goes on the final thing I'd say about
leadership is alignment and when I say
alignment most people would think you
know you've got an organization you
better align your organization you got
vision for a company you have values
you've got goals that's all true but you
have to actually be aligned further up
the chain you have to be aligned all the
way from your shareholders through your
board through your senior leadership
team through the employees I think a lot
of companies get in trouble when their
shareholders are misaligned in some ways
with their companies
and as warren buffett that said you know
a company gets the shareholders that the
company deserves yes if you've got a
bunch of shareholders are kind of just
doing wild things well you haven't
clearly aligned your shareholders with
what the company is trying to do and
what their expectation should be so
that's around leadership and I think at
this stage I'll stop and take questions
first of all you know I've had many many
mentors in my life one of the things
about life is about learning you have to
constantly want to learn and I know you
all are young enough and you're at a
great school and doing great things that
that might feel pretty normal to you but
people tend to either slow down on their
learning path which is I think not a
good thing because you want to be
curious at all times so that you can
grow as the world changes but I've had
frankly great mentors along the way and
I've learned something from a lot of
people who are around me both frankly
from the positive side and I'm from the
negative side which is you watch people
you go this person does this really well
and you watch that person and you see
how that person is kind of honed the
particular skill equally you can learn
from you know others doing things and
not doing them well and knowing not to
do that and actually you know my
personal journey from India to
California thirty years and now in the
UK for the last three years is is a is a
story that has had a lot of luck in it
frankly and I'm father I meant to say
that about leadership which is don't
take yourself too seriously okay just
you just because you kind of make it up
that doesn't mean that you're better
than anybody
okay luck plays a hugely important role
I'll give you two quick examples in my
my own case so I was graduating from
high school and I wanted to be in the
Air Force flying planes and my mother
said no you you you know you won't go to
this particular institution I had no
idea what I was going to do with my life
because she said I couldn't be an air
force officer so some friends of mine
had an extra-extra application form for
this institution called IITs which are
engineering schools I had no desire to
be an engineer anyway I took one of
these forms fill the form out took the
exam got in and then it became gosh you
really don't want to be an engineer but
you've gotten into an IIT and you some
of you may not be able to relate to this
but it's kind of sort of a big deal if
you get into an IIT I so it's like okay
so now are you gonna do you're gonna go
to an IIT or you're gonna you know be a
bum so all right so you go to an IIT now
here you are studying engineering I had
no interest in engineering but I kept
doing well okay so then you graduate
from your class you you you know again
did I want to come here to the United
States to study not particularly that
was not my goal
but everybody who is a smart kid was
applying to the United States so I to
apply the next thing you're admitted to
Berkeley I know it's not Stanford but
it's perfect I'll tell you
Berkeley has a better reputation
internationally than Stanford us believe
believe me
back in 1975 absolutely true today I'm
sure you know John Hennessy would say
run I'm gonna challenge that anyway so
you come to Berkeley you study
engineering for another two years now
you're into engineering seven years
still not interested in engineering okay
so then you Brett you know then I did a
business I've studied engineering for
seven years and I haven't practiced it
for one day okay so I mean and I can
keep going on here in terms of luck
plays a huge role you know you can't
actually design your career completely I
remember when I first joined Pacific
Tallis's group a couple of us joined on
the same day and I was given the
assignment this is in 1984 to look at
the mobile business the cellular
business and tell the senior executives
whether this is a good business or not a
good business and how big it was going
to be and all of that and this my
colleague who joined was given a similar
assignment on the publishing side so
both of us came in I got the mobile
charter and he got the publishing
charter and the mobile business grew to
be a huge business that we sold the
world of one for seventy-five billion
dollars whereas my colleague you know
basically the publishing business didn't
go any way and we shut it down two years
later both of us hired on the same day
sitting in cubicles next to each other
okay so luck plays a very important role
in life
into your business which are very
different from yeah so the principle
criteria we use is first of all
political stability in a country you
know in our business we're very
capital-intensive business we typically
have to put down a billion or two
billion or sometimes ten billion dollars
just to kind of get service started in a
country so having political stability is
tremendously important the second thing
we look at is industry structure which
is you know is this country being run by
some kind of rogue general who will give
out another license to his son-in-law or
his brother or whatever so we are
looking for good industry structure good
regulatory structure we're looking
frankly for the ability for our company
to make money you know we have to be
able to see that there are revenues
there are profits there is real growth
in this country and finally that we
uniquely can do something in that
country because if we can't do something
unique in that country the question is
why should we be there as opposed to
somebody else so I'd say those are the
four acquisition criteria as it were
that we use equally in terms of
integration we have a very big tent at
Vodafone as you can imagine the number
of cultures that we cross is massive so
if you think about our core values our
core values around passion for customers
passion for employees passion for
results and passion for the world around
us and then you can manifest each of
these things into local cultures in some
ways our brand values are around being
read passionate rock solid dependable
Restless EDD this is kind of you know
are you constantly innovating and you're
thinking about new stuff to do so if you
can look at it from a core value
standpoint you can look at it from a
brand standpoint picture big-tent
make sure that cultures are kind of
respected in the process but equally at
the end of the day those are the four
things that we draw
into each of our operating companies I
asked myself that question a lot too so
you know in today's environment in the
communications business I'd say I'm
spending between 15 and 20 percent of my
time on communicating with the important
stakeholders whether it's my
shareholders whether it's my employees
whether it's industry leadership I'd say
a fifth of my time is actually talking
to people helping them understand where
vodafone is going I think it's a
disproportionately large number frankly
and it's a disproportionately large
number because we've got shareholders in
Britain we've got shareholders in the
United States we've got shareholders in
Asia we've got shareholders everywhere
the industry is changing our company is
changing and change is hard you know
people talk about change management and
this and that take all that theory in
and then kind of make it more complex
than that and that's how hard change is
so you have to communicate clearly with
people about where the firm is cause I'd
say that would be 20 percent of my time
I'd say I I would spend typically 30
percent of my time with customers and
the remaining 50 percent of the time
what I'll call operations reviews and
people reviews you know just you've got
60,000 people every one of these people
wants to be the CEO of Vodafone and so
the point is you know how do you kind of
bring people a lot essentially that's
how I spend my time yes
you know at this stage I'd say what
drives me is the ability to make a
difference and the ability to do good
you know you're in a unique position you
know whether it is in corporate social
responsibility whether it's in running a
professional ethical high energy
business whether it is the ability to
influence governments to kind of do the
right thing the ability to develop
products that will be useful for society
so I think you know at this stage it's
about you know making sure that Vodafone
is doing good because Vodafone is a very
large part of the economy of virtually
every country that we do business in
it's just massive
I mean it's now been proven that
countries that have good mobile
telecommunications infrastructure if you
have 10 percent higher penetration in a
country the GDP that you're producing is
0.7 percent higher for having every ten
percentage points more in penetration so
we're in some ways a lubricant for
commerce and a lubricant for running
countries so the ability to do good is
enormous yes
how do you see supplier relations and
how vertically-integrated do you think
wireless operator should be yeah so
first of all I'll tell you any come any
company that is not guarding jealousy
jealously their customer relationships
is a company in trouble okay
we we've spent billions and billions of
dollars bringing on board these hundred
and eighty million subscribers that we
have so obviously we guard our customers
very very tightly your question is more
around okay so you know do we have a
walled garden around all our content or
is it going to be open or what's going
to happen here so when we first started
providing internet like services to our
customers we started off with a walled
garden because frankly we didn't know
what the customers wanted customers
frankly didn't know what they wanted in
the mobile space and so the easiest
relationship we could develop with our
with our customers was one where we gave
them a walled garden experience now
frankly wall Gardens don't last for a
very long time because there are lots of
people with big chainsaws that are kind
of cutting holes into wall gardens and
frankly that's the process that we're
going through so today if you ask me is
Vodafone a walled garden yes we are walk
on five years from now do you think we'd
be a wall garden absolutely not because
now as web 2.0 kind of comes alive in
some ways and whether it's an eBay or
it's Google or it's a Yahoo or it's a
Microsoft or whoever it is each one of
these people want entry into our
customers and to our portal we will give
them this entry
but now the economics and who's doing
what is much clearly understood and I
think you'll see the walled garden
opening up and Vodafone and other
companies you know providing access to
content now if you take the question
further and say will we be developing
original content ourselves highly
unlikely now frankly we're not any good
at
you know making animation movies or
making music or making television
programs other people do that much
better and I think that's that's an
important concept which is you've got to
do what you're really good at we're very
good at acquiring customers we're very
good with customer relationships in CRM
we're very good with billing we're very
good at providing basic services
we're not movies we're not movie people
yes
you know we we are quite proud of our
Foundation and our Foundation does great
things in a number of different
countries let me give you an example
from South Africa where we went to
places where frankly nobody wanted to go
and people thought we were absolutely
crazy kind of doing business in certain
parts of Africa certain parts of South
Africa and we actually took these
shipping containers and took them to
South Africa and put them down in places
that are hard to do business in and now
if you look at these containers they're
almost like the anchor tenant in a
shopping mall a whole bunch of industry
has set up right around them because
inside these containers we have three or
four boots we've got mobile phones we've
hired a local person and said you're the
local entrepreneur do you want to kind
of resell our service so we are
employing people people have access to
the mobile phones these people come in
to these boots call their villages call
whoever right next to these containers
now our shops that have you know selling
vegetables or fruit or bread or whatever
the case might be and you go to these
places now and you go my god I mean we
had no idea that we would be able to
influence their lives so much and that's
one example of what we're doing
so the direction we're interested in
moving our cash flows is up and and in
terms in terms of where we might use
this cash flow you know if you go back
to what I said about what we want to do
our view is we don't need to own any
land lines you know land lines is a
business of the past if you have it you
got it and you know no problem you know
make a reasonable rate of return and you
know do what you have to do but our view
is that the world is actually going I P
Internet Protocol so all our products
and services are I P based products you
know a lot of our competitors have
mobile companies and have landline
companies and they're trying to bring
these two companies together to kind of
you know say to a customer you can do
this and this together well that's
interesting but that's not what the
customer really wants what the customer
wants is a broadband connection and once
unlimited Wireless using IP so that's
the that's the direction we are going in
and my view is we'll end up you know
getting into the fixed line business but
in an infrastructure light way which is
buying access rather than having copper
wires in the back
so voice-over-ip developments in mobile
are clearly going to happen
they're obviously happening in very
large quantities on a landline side
they'll come to the mobile industry in
the mobile industry there are one or two
complexities in terms of the pace at
which voice over IP will come in for one
there are two billion cell phone users
out there so to kind of change out two
billion cell phone users is going to
take you know the next five six seven
ten years the second is is you know for
voice over IP you need kind of a data
pipe and you need to have broadband
systems we have invested at Vodafone
incredible amount of money in this 3G
technology that creates a data pipe so
we're going to be the leaders in this
space in the mobile business and it's
very different from landlines because in
landlines the access is much easier and
international calling rates are higher
and therefore you know the sense of
arbitrage is much greater so my view is
voice over IP in the wireless world
comes in two three four years in large
quantities in the precisely that I
wanted to run a company that had 180
million customers know to be candid with
you I didn't have a clue this continues
with not having a clue I graduated I
went to work for a management consulting
firm this is 1978 energy was really hot
you know oil prices were going through
the roof kind of sounds familiar these
days and so I went to work for IEA back
in Washington DC I was with them for
three years then went to work for one of
my clients Natomas company a SAN
francisco-based oil and gas company and
Natomas was acquired by diamond shamrock
a texas-based company
and my wife didn't want to move to Texas
so she said well go out and kind of
pound the pavement and find yourself a
job in San Francisco just at this time
AT&T was breaking up and talked about
déjà vu AT&T breaking up we've we've
reformed AT&T
all right so AT&T was breaking up 20
plus years ago and they were looking for
somebody who'd done strategy and M&A and
all of that and I went to work for the
phone company and and then I told you
the story about you know being assigned
to the mobile side and then you know one
thing led to another
frankly again if you'd asked me did I
have a preference for a larger company
you know frankly I've always kind of
gone back and forth there are things
about small companies and
entrepreneurial companies that are
hugely exciting and for me for whatever
set of reasons I was equally attracted
to a large company as well just because
of the resources and this notion of the
ability to kind of do good as it were
which I think you have less often a
smaller company than you then you have
in a larger company in other words I
didn't have a clue I just kind of went
forward and whatever seemed interesting
and exciting I did I I do have to say
something as much as this sounds
completely unplanned and kind of random
and all of that is I have enjoyed every
single day of my working life I'm this
may be a bit of an exaggeration but
but I haven't been in a job for a long
time when what the heck am I doing here
you know I'm adding no value you know I
might shall do something else and maybe
those thoughts came to my mind and I did
go on to something else but I have
enjoyed every bit of what I've done in
the last 2530 years which is again a
very very lucky thing yes and you've
touched on briefly having a daughter
here at Stanford and a wife who's had
some impact on choices you've made can
you talk about your ability or sort of
anchors in your life or other sort of
rules you've lived by that have helped
you manage a family and and being being
there for your wife and kids despite
having sort of trajectory that's taking
you to the top of a large company so
first off you know the one rule that
I've tried to keep at the forefront at
all times is do the right thing I know
this is not central to your question
I'll come on to it but the point here is
as you think about who you are and what
you're doing and the choices that you
have to make do the right thing is kind
of the big picture thing now frankly if
my if my wife was here you know we've
had to make some tough choices and you
know she was she was working and very
successful career and you know I moved
around a fair amount so as a family we
had to make choices you know I missed a
lot of Nina's piano recitals and soccer
games and all of that so the point I'm
making is you know as a family as a
person if you do intend to do kind of
things that people consider big things
there are tough choices to be made
there's no kind of easy I'm going to
have it all and I've found kind of a an
elixir to
be able to do it all there are tough
choices to be made and I've gotta tell
you I mean I not sure I got it wrong I
got a right all the time so you make
mistakes but my advice to you is find
somebody who either ends up being your
wife your husband your partner or
whoever it is who kind of understands
who you are and where you want to go
because otherwise they'll be conflict
yes very
so no clearly you know I I don't know if
anybody who's just had a completely
straight line career and the mistakes
that I would say I've made have been
mistakes about people you know when I've
misjudged a situation and you kind of
say you know I'm gonna go do this with
thus and such and you go there and the
picture is different from the picture
that you thought and so and again you
know my view is if you're going to do a
lot of things you know this is all about
improving your odds it's all about
probability you want to do more things
right and a few things wrong and you
want to minimize the wrong things and
you want to maximize the right things
but in my case I'd say the mistakes have
been principally on my judgment on
people and the wid handle it is frankly
to kind of say I'm going to learn from
this and I'm not going to do it again
and just put it in your DNA what was the
mistake that I made that last time and
is there a kind of a pattern recognition
thing here am I getting ready to make
another mistake or can I learn something
from what the key is as long as you're
learning from every experience both good
and bad you're gonna be okay
yes new services are available to mobile
phone users it's a messaging mobile
search things like that I see there are
a lot of other interesting technologies
on the horizon in the mobile space from
payments to location-based advertising
to old television location-based social
networking things like that I was
wondering if you could just talk a
little bit about which of those are most
exciting to you so let me let me
categorize the answer in two buckets one
is anything and everything you see on a
broadband wired Internet service today
you will be able to get wirelessly so
whether it's options whether it's
commerce whether it's whatever you can
think about it including VoIP whatever
it is you'll be able to get on your own
your mobile phones principally because
in in the mobile phone industry we too
are going broadband so we have broadband
pipes maybe not as broad as the landline
broadband pipes but plenty broad for
most people and the second is devices
are becoming very interchangeable you
know not everybody just as interested in
a small phone you've got you've got PDAs
you've got a number of things that are
going to come between a computer and a
small mobile phone so you'll see many
many devices music devices television
devices commerce devices email devices
obviously the second is mobility offers
some unique things such as location
based stuff so there'll be some things
that will do uniquely because our stuff
is portable in mobile but everything you
can think of on a wired broadband
connection you can find on a wireless
device
yeah okay so music music mobile TV
location-based commerce synced devices
would be the top form okay
we're gonna tell you how much money you
can make an eternal version when you get
to an IP everywhere environment like
that are you scared that then you become
just a bit provider and less the service
provider yeah so you know this notion of
IP everywhere is clearly going to happen
I mean you've got a campus like this
which is completely IP and so on and so
forth but first of all you know I think
of IP stuff in the next five years or so
it's kind of local area stuff whereas we
are genuinely in the wide area business
you can go anywhere in the United States
almost again and get a mobile signal if
you can be Europe you'd find the service
really good and there's a reason for
that because the government's in Europe
forced us to build our entire countries
whereas here the United States nobody
asked us to build anything out outside
of kind of economic self-interest in
building things out so what you find
here is big holes and all of that but
the point here is IP things are more
local and mobile things are more wide
area now if you said okay everyone let's
go out 20 30 years my view is obviously
if you go out 20 30 years clearly there
will be more and more IP around the
world in terms of bit byte versus non
bit pipe I actually find that kind of
not a really relevant point of
discussion because the point is we will
be in in the access business will be in
the monetization of our customer
relationship business will be in the
e-commerce business will be in the you
know again monetization of entertainment
whether it's music whether it's TV
whether it's movies whatever it is
many other businesses in today I am
worried do I lose sleep over it not yet
and what I mean by that is you
absolutely right in our case actually
the voice is 80% of our revenues but if
you think about again the business that
we're in we're in the mobility business
okay now yes you can have voice over IP
yes you can have dual-mode phones yes
you can do Wi-Fi short distance but the
minute you come out of the campus here
you'll still need our 3G services so the
world we are going to is a world where
we used to charge on a per minute basis
we've now migrated to a world where
we've got big bundles and I certainly
hope all of you have big bundles from
Verizon and in the future we'll be
selling you data bundles so you can do
voice over IP and you can do you know
regular voice calling as well
now the question will become okay but if
voice is free you know I've been hearing
about voice being free for almost 10
years now and voice is not free yet okay
and you might say but but but it is with
voice over IP but it is because I can
call my aunt in South Africa and it's a
free call yeah segments of voice are
free the other point is you're paying
for the broadband connection so it's not
really free you may think of it as free
because the incremental cost to you is
zero but it's not really free I'm not
don't get my comment wrong in terms of
do I think prices of mobile phones and
everything else is
gonna come down it's coming down 15% a
year so you try growing a business
decide the size of Vodafone where the
unit price is falling 15% a year by any
reasonable growth rate to keep a market
cap of 150 billion dollars it's tough so
that's why do I think about it I think
about it all the time am i hugely
concerned not at this stage because we
have to find new revenue streams for the
future and that's the challenge that's
the core of the business yes ma'am in
Japan strategy in Japan for those of you
who may not know we've just come out of
Japan we you know people have written
off our business in Japan completely and
we just sold the business for fifteen
billion dollars so we came out of Japan
I'd say principally because of two
things one is if you again think about
industry structure in the future the way
the Japanese mobile market is evolving
it was very hard for us to see how we
would make money for our shareholders
long term the second is there's always
this concept of can somebody else do a
better job then you can and I think this
is an important principle for all of you
which is don't ever fall into the trap
of thinking that just because you're
large and you've got a big brand and
you've got blah blah blah that you're
the naturally chosen one to kind of do
something in our case we got an offer
from a company called Softbank that's in
the fixed line business there and
they're in the internet business there
are a number of other businesses in the
content business and they came to us and
said if we had mobile we could package
this up and we could actually give you a
very high price for your asset and when
we looked at it in those terms we felt
that that was the best thing to do and
again for you know
- just talk about Japan for a minute
Japan's a tough market
Japan's tough market to make money in
it's a difficult market to make money in
because many of your competitors have a
very different headset about what the
opportunity cost of capital is you know
we all sit here we're all kind of
familiar with what goes on on Wall
Street or the city and kind of the
amount of money you have to make and
cost a capital and all that well because
you're in a zero percent interest rate
market the headset that you have in
Japan as to what you need to earn is
very different from most of us who have
to earn a reasonable rate of return
otherwise our shareholders get very
upset so when you kind of take all of
that into account you kind of say
alright masa here's the business you
give us the 15 billion and we'll give
you our customers and as you can tell
we're getting money next week I'm very
much looking forward to it will tells me
that times up I've got to stop so it's
been fantastic to see all of you all the
best to you in your careers you know one
of the things you may not know you are
sitting here at Stanford University in
Stanford in in the South Bay this is
this is a fabulous place I've had the
opportunity to travel around the world
meet you know great people from around
the world this is very special you may
not recognize it today but I'm sure
you'll recognize that in 10 or 20 years
all the best